there aren't long lineups outside this
toronto vaccine clinic anymore just
people slowly trickling in most for a
third dose i have my booster my mom has
my booster and all of the family has the
booster
a new ongoing study out of ontario finds
mrna vaccines are 93 percent effective
at protecting against delta infection
seven days post booster but when it
comes to omicron the number falls to 60
percent only have two doses scientists
found after six months there was no
protection against canada's most
dominant strain the issue is that
omicron is just so much different than
the previous variants you know the
vaccines work really well against all
the variants up till delta similar
findings have also come out of the u.s
and researchers say it underscores the
need for third and even fourth doses for
anyone who is immunocompromised
in ontario that is now being offered but
it's what scientists didn't find that
stands out as the most important
takeaway of all not a single booster
recipient who contracted covid ended up
in hospital it's not a 100 guarantee you
won't end up in hospital but it really
significantly reduces
that chance but as more and more people
are discovering it doesn't mean you're
not going to get covered those who do
will have natural antibodies at least
for a period of time in that case
experts say you don't have to rush to
immediately get another shot you want to
boost when your antibody levels have
started to decline you don't need to
boost once your antibody levels are high
meantime vaccine manufacturers are
trying to keep up with science that can
measure up to be able to ward off
omicron too jamie morocco global news
toronto